pendant que les grandes économies
mondiales va si on en parlait à
l'instant une autre crise sévit en
silence celle là la sécheresse qui
frappe depuis le printemps plusieurs
pays d'afrique de l'est a anéanti les
récoltes ainsi en ethiopie plus de 12
millions de personnes ont besoin de la
solidarité internationale
cent mille enfants au moins souffrent de
malnutrition silva la can et laurent
beaufils se sont rendus sur place par
centaines ils arrivent ce jour là de
toute la région les habitants de cette
petite ville du nord de l'ethiopie
attendait ce moment depuis des semaines
un camion vient d'amener de la
nourriture des tonnes de sorgho fournis
par la communauté internationale pour
ces familles qui n'ont plus rien à
manger
cette distribution est vitale car la
sécheresse qui frappe le pays a anéanti
leurs récoltes
j'ai eu 12 kg de sorgho avec ça je vais
pouvoir tenir une semaine à l'image de
la gagne dans le calme
chacun attend patiemment d'être appelé
mais il n'y aura pourtant pas assez de
nourriture pour tout le monde car le
programme alimentaire mondial manque de
dons afin d'acheter suffisamment de
céréales mois et ne m'ont rien donné
j'ai sept enfants et je n'ai quasiment
plus rien à manger
un peu plus loin dans ce centre de santé
la situation est également tendue ces
mères viennent faire soigner leurs
enfants qui souffrent de malnutrition à
deux ans qui tint à mariam ne pèse que 7
kg pour réalimenter la petite fille
l'infirmière des livres à sa mère une
ration d'une semaine de plumpy'nut une
pâte d'arachide très nutritive fournis
par la communauté internationale mais
les stocks sont insuffisants pour faire
face à cette crise il nous manque
l'unicef des dons à hauteur de 14
millions d'euros pour couvrir les
besoins jusqu'à la fin de l'année
l'ethiopie dispose pourtant d'une usine
de plumpy'nut dans la région d'addis
abeba la capitale
elle a été créée il ya un an pour
résorber les problèmes de malnutrition
chronique qui frappe le pays
mais face à l'ampleur de cette crise sa
production est insuffisante
lusine ne possède qu'une seule chaîne de
conditionnement actuellement produit 150
tonnes de plumpy nut par mois faux
répond à cette crise il faudra en
produire 5 fois plus
l'unicef et les ong doivent donc en
importer plus de 500 tonnes de
l'étranger mais importé du plumpy'nut
par avion coûte beaucoup plus cher alors
que les fonds sont déjà insuffisants le
transport fait grimper la facture de ces
palettes qui arrivent d'europe de 50% et
les lenteurs administratives vont
retarder la distribution dans les
faubourgs de la capitale
le plumpy'nut est déchargé dans ce
hangar de l'unicef depuis deux semaines
c'est 160 tonnes n'ont toujours pas été
acheminés vers les centres de santé du
pays
car malgré l'urgence l'administration
éthiopienne n'a toujours pas procédé aux
formalités de dédouanement pour venir à
bout de cette crise les nations unies le
gouvernement éthiopien vont lancer un
nouvel appel aux dons de plus de 200
millions de dollars
mais comme souvent les sommes récoltées
risque d'être inférieure et la situation
pourrait encore s'aggraver dans le pays
revient francs